let's jump to this next story we got
from the post of millennial I love this
we have testimony that Joe Biden is on
the phone with Hunter Biden and his
Associates at the same time we have
testimony from one of Hunter's
Associates that Joe Biden is getting
Kickbacks and then CNN says Hunter Biden
was selling the illusion of access
because Joe was on the phone but Joe
wasn't talking shop
does he need to seriously if they're
sharing bank accounts sharing email
addresses if Joe Biden is taking us on
salary
it's like the mafia it's like the guys
talking negotiating a deal with the
other guy and he's like listen the Don
says he wants you to do this or else and
then they're like oh I'm not going to do
anything and all sudden the Don walks in
the front then goes how's these guys
doing and they're like oh everything's
good man we're doing everything you ask
and they run away
see they may they're trying to make this
claim that makes literally no sense the
moment you put Joe Biden the phone it's
a whip crack the vice president is in
the room well don't you forget it so I I
hear your point I agree with it but also
I I that claim is just not true I mean
this is um this was in the New York Post
the other week of of when apparently
there's a text from one of the Barista
Executives and he says to Hunter can you
ring your dad question mark and then
Hunter
um
placed him on speaker phone and uh sorry
this was not a text this must have been
a call
um he but hunter goes on speakerphone
with Joe Biden and and says these guys
quote need our support so I mean he
wasn't just selling the illusion of
access he was putting these guys on
speakerphone with his dad and and
telling his dad we need to help them so
where is that from that's from New York
Post
yes I think it's fair to say that CNN is
desperately lying and what what is the
scene at Oracle look like I'm actually
curious to see how they frame that other
than post millennial
think this is it former business partner
says Hunter Biden Soul form illusion of
access to Joe Biden yes former business
partner says Source says that is so
ridiculous
that's hilarious
four business partners
a couple a couple Degrees of Separation
I'm surprised they published that
possible deniability right there
yeah we know
um it is like Tim as you were doing your
mafia metaphor it's like if the if the
mob member was like hey we got a job for
you but before you go you're gonna take
my son along like how is that not Mafia
interference with the kid the guy's son
the mob member's son he's bringing his
son along for the game oh it's like this
crackhead is all of a sudden invite
along the son of the boss goes to uh
like a bunch of guys who are delivery
guys or you know drivers or meals or
whatever and it's like I want you guys
to move all this product my dad wants it
done they go your dad doesn't want this
done this is your job you're trying to
Upstate you just like gets on the phone
says Hey Dad how you doing and then his
dad's like everything's going good son
he's like yeah I'm here with the boys
they're saying everything's good right
boys so he didn't talk shop but come on
well we know exactly what that was well
but I
yeah I agree like even if you're doing
that it's still up but like that
isn't that isn't even what Biden was
doing like Joe is clearly more involved
than that what it's like the dirtiest
stuff he was doing do you have the data
on on the quotes or like any any
specific the specific like the three
most corrupt things that he did that we
have like documented proof of or extreme
amounts of evidence well I guess I don't
know like you know policy like which
policies arose from it I just mean like
the text
um I don't know if there's anything that
originates actually from Joe but just
like the text that Tim referenced
earlier of Hunter saying
um you know you know pops he's like he's
talking to his remember his daughter or
something he's like pops takes 50 of all
my I'm not gonna do that to you
when you get older so I mean like why
would Hunter lie about that you know
what I mean like that so it's in private
texts yeah exactly and so that's one
example
um I guess we don't have here from New
York Post how Joe responded to these
guys need our help but oh oh but there
is a timeline this so this was like
it was like
um it was like a matter of weeks later
that he gave that speech we played and
he got the guy fired
um so yeah I mean the timeline lines up
as well like Dad these guys need our
support week couple weeks go by uh I
lost prosecutors fired I love that
they're like Joe was on the phone with
Hunter's Associates a couple dozen times
for no reason yeah he didn't talk shop
it's like wait wait two dozen times on
the phone with these guys what were they
talking about going golfing or is that
what Joe was or Hunter was Joe was on
the phone on speakerphone over 20 times
with Hunter Biden's Associates that's
what Devin Archer tested oh wow so the
question is like for what reason it's
like it's not a social yeah exactly
which is all which is another reason
that CNN article is ridiculous like did
they include that fact in there like it
was kind of just the illusion but also
they were on the phone two dozen times I
really do feel like unless the Democrats
decide that they're gonna replace Joe
Biden for uh
running for president as the candidate I
don't think that there's anything that's
going to happen no matter what the
evidence comes out no matter who says
anything because I think Merrick Garland
is is incredibly corrupt I don't think
that he's gonna I think that he's he's
gonna protect the bidens as much as
possible and and it's it sucks to be so
black pilled but really I mean
the evidence is overwhelming that that
it's worth having hearings about and and
you know you can barely get and
Democrats don't even want to you know
hear hear the the evidence so I I just I
hate the fact that I'm a black pillar at
the beginning though that you think they
are gonna replace Joe Biden no no I said
unless they're going unless they start
to really like wind up uh Gavin Newsom
or whatever okay I love it I love that
hairy Sisson guy because he's like 20.
but he's got the education of like a
third grader and I'm not saying to be
mean I'm saying quite literally he
tweeted out that uh I was at Alito
Supreme Court said that uh Congress has
no authority to regulate them and he was
shocked by it and I'm like bro we
learned that in like second grade it's
called the branches of government
they they're they're all equal branches
of government they have no power over
each other they have degrees of power
over each other for checks and balances
that's about it but he really doesn't
get it and then he recently posted a
photo I bring him up because he posted a
photo of Joe Biden looking horrifying
and he was like he looks so cool it's
like dude how much did he you know I
gotta be honest if you're like dark
Brandon if you're a gen Z dude and
you're following that guy and you agree
that flabby skipping leg day Joe Biden
is cool looking oh I'm sorry man the
hairy Sisson thing's interesting it's
him and his buddy they just kind of
appeared out of nowhere and they're like
these young kind of good-looking like
young guys and they do that frenetic
thing where they do this a lot like the
dash do Broski thing but it caught on I
guess it's like a meme yeah I was just
trying to find the clip now there's a
hilarious one where he's just like
frantically like he doesn't take a
breath and and it's he's just talking
but it's hilarious but what I think your
point about those guys show the you're
putting them come on that'd be fun but
your point about those guys coming out
of nowhere I I think like I think 100
um those guys would not have a huge
following if like the right didn't just
make make fun of them all the time I
think that's main
all their followers are the right making
fun of them so but on purpose that's why
I see them they're doing that on purpose
the right doesn't want to prop up the
most articulate liberal speaker they
want to prop up the worst and most
pathetic liberal speaker so then they
can knock them down but blow them you
know straw man yeah basically be like oh
look at this guy in his arguments yeah
you know if there's someone who's very
calm and makes a well-reasoned liberal
argument nobody's gonna be outraged they
might respond and be like I think you're
wrong about this and they'll send a link
and then that no one cares right but you
find someone who is genuinely ignorant
of the facts but screaming about
nonsense and you're just like this is a
spectacle yeah this is but do you think
Harry Sisson is doing that on purpose I
think he's getting paid to do it yeah I
I think that paid by who he works for
some well he works for some talent
agency not directly he worked for some
talent agency that gets funding from
certain Democratic groups so I've seen
reporting oh okay and he he gets paid to
post I mean my that's my assumption
based on the news report I could be
wrong but it's clout building okay
everybody who generates followers is
going to make money from doing it okay
but I thought you were saying like he's
intentionally being stupid and ignorant
because he knows it'll rally up the
conservatives and that's true too but so
then why would the DNC pay to like
embarrass themselves with a guy like
Harrison someone said they were smart
but it's but but I think you're you're
thinking too absolutely right there are
people who post things intentionally
stupid because it generates attention I
post troll posts and then the media
takes them serious I once said impeach
the queen and I had a whole article
written about Tim Poole journalist calls
for the impeachment of Queen Elizabeth
before she passed and I'm just like what
it was a joke I can't believe they
didn't impeach her yeah but they're like
each the queen possibly
[Music]
I don't even remember why I said to
impeach her like she had something had
happened I guess she was not woke enough
I don't have no idea you know but yeah a
lot of these people on social media they
uh
just say utter nonsense to get followers
that's a good observation you were
saying that people will retweet or
repost like the cringe stuff because
it's so bad you're like you want hey
everyone I want you to see how horrible
this is so you know what you're up
against but I see it and it's like I
just feel like you're that guy talking
to me when you repost him so like I have
to unfollow people when they repost
trash content to make fun of it I don't
I don't want that trash content in my
life I understand the mentality of like
yeah and then you're awesome and then
you're also like you're you're
convincing yourself of like a caricature
of the left that isn't true and then
you're not prepared like if you want to
debate the left you're not really
prepared on what they actually believe
and then like also in in like your
everyday life you might know like most
of my friends and family members are
like left wing and so if like if I if I
look at Harry Sisson and I'm like oh but
then if I get in a real conversation
with like my relatives I I I'm gonna be
like unprepared I'm gonna be like oh
they're actually a lot smarter and like
I should I should you know I don't know
it would be obviously better than
everyone agree I certainly think Harry
Susan is a caricature of liberals who's
like it's shot content but his
understanding of reality is about on par
with the average liberal voter they
could not point to Ukraine on a map and
there's varying degrees of this but I
gotta tell you man I agree with that the
the the the the key moment a good
example is when we had Hunter Avalon on
this show and I said in one example that
Joe Biden said if you don't file the
prosecutor not getting a billion dollars
and he smugly said that never happened
and then I played the video and he was
like uh whoops it's like dude I don't I
don't I don't care for debate like in
this idea that we're gonna stand on the
stage and hit a buzzer and be like well
I have an argument and do different
debate tactics that's stupid I care
about hear the things that I think
here's why I think them if you are wrong
I will say you're wrong I'll pull
something up if it turns out I'm wrong
I'll say I was wrong about that right I
agree but that's that is a debate that's
like the point of what my point is I
have no concern or fear of debating a
liberal on any of these issues at all
and I don't think I know everything
about these issues I in fact think I'm
mostly wrong because you're open to
discovering the truth the Deep State the
intelligence agencies are not giving us
the true and correct information about
what's going on but what I can say is
I've read substantially more about all
of this than any of you and I do believe
if the average if you took an SD card
and neural linked it all the basic news
coverage of Ukraine and Joe Biden into
the head of the average liberal they
vote Donald Trump instantly
it's just that they don't know they
don't want to know they watch CNN and
that's about it
or MSNBC and they believe people like
Rachel Maddow who who's nearly in tears
When Donald Trump isn't indicted as a
Russian spy they may not vote Trump but
they'll definitely not vote Biden they
vote Trump I'm kind of that guy I just
I'm not I don't immediately go to the
opposite part about that or RFK if you
downloaded all of the information on the
Biden family Ukraine and the war the
Obama Administration just all the news
articles Hillary all her emails yeah
into their brains they would just be
like now I understand why everyone's
voting Trump a full red pill full red
pill but if you go to a trump supporter
and you were to download them to their
brands all of the news articles about
Donald Trump the unfor the the the thing
is most Trump supporters would be like
these are contradictions this is the
point if you so my favorite uh two
stories from Politico one that the
Democrats were uh that Ukraine said that
there were Democrats trying to interfere
in the 2016 election or something effect
then you have a several years later
Politico reporting once again that in
fact that was Russian disinformation but
never retracting or correcting their own
reporting saying otherwise how can
Politico run two stories one making a
claim and one saying that claim was
Russian disinformation without
correcting because it's garbage nonsense
now the fact that I know those two
articles exists gives me some Keen
insight into what's really going on in
the world especially considering who the
journalist was who wrote the second
article you put those articles into the
minds of the average person and they're
going to be like something's not right
here Trump supporters already know the
news contradicts itself and lies all the
time many of these liberals just believe
Rachel Maddow and they think Fox News is
lying granted not a big fan of Sean
Hannity you know but Tucker Carlson was
pretty good thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time